so vanessa i'm really curious what your
thoughts on this are as a suburban
mother of young children what do you
think of this idea that someone's
actively trying to sew discord between
you and the people who literally live
next door to you yeah i mean
i already feel outnumbered by my
community because i'm i lean
conservative obviously and um you know
i'm smack in the middle of
dc a suburb in dc and um
you know
it's funny
somebody made a comment about how you
can tell who the conservatives are
because they're the ones who are flying
the american flags
and um
you know
somebody asked me when i was when i was
gonna vote uh you know would you put the
person's name up in your yard and the
answer was no i i don't i really don't
want my neighbors to know my politics i
i don't i don't want to have the
conversation i've got a nice
big jeep that i don't want messed with i
um this is why
the cult forms because these people
they think
it makes me not want to engage and
that's what's scary what i'm saying is
if they don't ever see it they assume
it's fringe or doesn't exist yeah and
there's probably a bunch of people in
your neighborhood who do agree with you
but the people who are in the cult
think everyone thinks the same way they
do because you don't want to put signs
up in your yard if i did not have two
very small children
i would be a little more fearless about
it but i don't i mean
i i i don't wan i don't want my stuff
smashed because somebody sees you know
maybe if i was supporting trump i don't
want them seeing a trump sticker you
know whoever runs i i suppose the the
the issue then is if you think you can
keep your head down and they won't come
and smash your stuff you're wrong and by
your your unwillingness to actually
stand up for yourself is only making the
problem worse no i mean that's that's a
i mean you know and i i work with um
i work with some different groups who
are recruiting
parents to run for school board and
that's you know this is the big
conversation that they're having too
which is you know how how like are you
going to be
too scared to get up in your community
to really
like help kind of con take back the
education system
it's it's it's this is what i'm saying
though suburban mom it is scary because
you you have to worry about
about your kids and how your kids are
going to fit in and how people are going
to treat your children and that's why um
well i also think that my demographic is
the hardest to figure out where we're at
politically because
most women i think feel my way it's like
we're going to vote how we vote but
we don't want to talk about it why would
you want your kids hanging out with
their kids no you're right they're going
to be grooming your kids this is a
conversation that i've had with my
husband too about leaving the area um
and going to a red state even even even
uh
eastern west virginia and it's funny to
say eastern
the schools have been infiltrated by
by the world because when they when they
run for school board they don't put any
affiliation and they don't they
they know they have to lie when the when
the republicans were questioning those
witnesses the other day and they refused
to condemn infanticide it's because they
know if they admitted their position
people would recoil in horror so they
know they have to lie so what happens is
in these west virginian schools you have
wokeness critical race theory and gender
ideology and they tell the kids hide it
from your parents it's even in west
virginia you got to go deeper into
western you get away from it and there's
been a big backlash where locals finally
started figuring out what's going on
with their kids and now people are
pulling their kids out that's that's a
big that's happening
so i come from a single mom home
and
you know
we used to kind of joke i mean she she
was able to make it to all my soccer
games she made it all my sporting events
but she worked her butt off all the time
to make sure that my sister and i were
were supported and you know there was
one time i was busting her balls and
it's probably not even fair for me to
have done this looking back now but you
know she couldn't name my math teacher
one year
and how many
i mean
note these parents who work these
parents who don't have the capacity to
engage
with school boards all this stuff i mean
this you know critical race theory and
the gender ideology teachings it's it's
happening and parents have no idea and i
actually think it's worse with
these more rural schools without so many
eyes on them because
they they have staff that aren't really
being checked
like you know a a teacher can probably
get away with more because
you know the the parents aren't as tuned
in the school board's not as tuned in
they can kind of i don't know i i know
that there was some teachers kind of in
rural wisconsin who were getting in
trouble for this and
um
anyway to your point though my husband
and i have talked about leaving
and um
yeah it's it's west virginia yeah great
place to be you made a good point that
it's it's fiscal that people can't
afford to spend time to go to their
their child's school my mom was involved
because she had the luxury of having a
husband that worked yeah probably the
only reason she had to work she never
would have been she couldn't she
couldn't have done it so it's an
economic thing a lot of this is economic
and you have no obligation to stage your
partisanship publicly we have secret
ballots for a reason people that want a
virtue signal with signs in their yard
you're welcome to but no one is expected
to do that well that's why the joke in
my neighborhood is that the people who
are the ones you know flying american
flags which i do
that's our
way of saying that's our way it's it's
more subtle but i mean i don't think
it's really even that subtle i think
everyone in the neighborhood thinks that
i told seamus coughlin to put a rainbow
behind him a rainbow flag behind him on
the show and he said i think that would
send the wrong message and i said why
because the rainbow is god's covenant to
noah that he would not flood the earth
again and so i said why would you why
would you like not fly your own sign out
of fear that people would get the wrong
idea instead of just telling people what
the right idea is and standing behind
symbols that were historically used by
christians and he said
okay maybe it's like an actual rainbow
and it says something on it we made that
and i was like yes let's let's do that
so right now
you have people who are saying i will
not express my support for what i
believe in other than to subtly and
secretly do it in in a way like flying
the american flag okay well i i will say
that
for a lot of conservatives politics is
not our religion it's nowhere close to
our religion and the way the left views
politics it is their religion and so
you know i want to be judged by my
christian faith i want to be judged by
you know just not who i vote for and for
for me to
brand my home my car whatever with these
campaign signs with these campaign
stickers it's it's basically asking for
this
engagement with with somebody who
doesn't see the fight the same way i do
does that make sense totally yeah
there's more than two political parties
also people are blind some people are
blinded into the left right paradigm
well and that's and that's the other
thing too i have never like in the last
few elections there has not been a
candidate who i do fully support who i
do want to fly a flag for or hang up a
sign for because i don't i'm not wholly
behind that person um
and so i guess that's that's another
answer to your question but you know
when the left view
when the left views politics is religion
and i don't it takes away
my will to fight because it's like i'm
fighting with a crazy person who does
not have even the same value system as
as i do but engaging these people is
extremely important it's beyond a
different value system i remember
watching uh something when i was a
little kid i remember what it was
but it was something about religion
maybe it was like something i watched in
school and it was a christian
who was captured in a conflict with
uh muslims like it was like a crusades
thing or something like that and they
told him to renounce his god and he said
no and they were like if you don't
renounce your god we'll kill you and he
said then i'll die and then kill him and
i thought that was so dumb i'm like
you're saying words you're just saying
words like you will live if you just say
oh yeah oh man oh wow you're so right i
totally do and i never understood
because i i think you know try and
survive
but now
seeing what's going on in this country
and in this world with the woke
psychotic you know nonsense and watching
star trek the next generation
how many lights are there
and now i get it
you know so you see these people
it's not it's not just a difference of
values it is
you see
you you see the color blue they see the
color green they literally do not see
the same thing as you yeah and so it
doesn't matter what you say to them they
will get violent oh they will they will
they will attack you because they're in
a cult and they're in my wreck my jeep
it matters what you say you can you can
communicate if they see a symbol then
that's going to be challenging because
like for instance the not this nazi
swastika was like remnant of like a
hindu symbol of the wheel of life it's
like a it's like a mirror image of it so
if i were to put a mirror image of the
swastika behind me uh that's not going
to put forth a good message even though
i know it's a symbol of peace yeah it's
gonna piss a lot of people off i was in
austin and there's an antique shop it's
a famous antique shop and they got
swastikas all over the joint they're the
real ones not the nazi one they're the
inverted hindu ones
and i asked the guy about it and he said
he's like oh yeah i got out of my
keychain we've got mugs here and he's
like in the 19 early 1900s these were
all over everyone's houses they were
good luck symbols
and and then i was like you're not
worried about people seeing that and
he's like nope
and i was like oh okay like that's what
i'm saying like
i think that's that's bold
to be willing to be like i assert what
this means and you know do something
about it
i think there's a time and a place to to
utilize symbology for your cause because
if if the if the temperature was right
politically symbolism symbolism that i
could i could not say it's reference
sorry i had to do it i could show the
swastika reverse mirror image swastika
like i could do it if if the environment
was was ready for it yeah there then
it's oh then you can have the discussion
and show the symbol and but otherwise
it's just it's it's like it's like a
spark when there's when the with wet
wood it's not gonna set anything it's
not gonna catalyze anything it's just
gonna people are like why are you
setting that why are you trying to so
i'm gonna make the symbol for individual
liberty personal responsibility and
freedom like a puppy or something yeah
it's just gonna be like a little dog
like playing with a toy golden retriever
that's all it will be a baby golden
retriever on a flag because you have the
means to print these beautiful images on
flags these days yeah and then people
will be like marching angry like like
with this flag with like a little golden
retriever puppy like playfully playing
well that's basically what the left does
right like they yeah they
they wrap their craziness and pretty
untouchable packages and then uh we're
all evil for going against yeah like the
cato nine tails each lash is a different
color
beautiful yeah that's a great idea okay
before we move on i did want to say i
know it's different when you ask a mom
what she wants to do about it then when
you ask your dad what he's going to do
about it because moms take a very
different approach than dads can and
should and i also wanted to say that i
think this is a deeply cultural problem
because like ian was saying it does
require two incomes to survive like very
much where we are especially it's very
expensive to live i know the cost of
living isn't cheap both parents have to
be working to some extent and i
understand it's hard but at the same
time you could flip it on its head and
be that person who's so nice so friendly
and so involved in the community that
when they find out that you support
someone like i don't know um youngkin or
rob santos that's kind of always my goal
right you know i i always kind of find
that i i have a very very close-knit
group of friends and it i do have a lot
have a lot of friends guys
but you know those who
who i know feel differently than i do
politically i kind of wait right and
it's almost like i have this personal
moment where i come out to them and i i
get to kind of break it to them like
look i know you respect me as a person
as a mom as a friend i respect you and
it's it's sad but it feels like in this
area because everybody is so hyper
political um
you know you you have to kind of own or
earn that trust first as a as somebody
who leans conservative before you
break it to them
i got an idea oh boy what you do is you
hold a local community gathering
and you say it's going to be a big event
party for pride or something
yeah when people show up with my puppy
dog flag what they're gonna see is you
get you get a venue with a bunch of tvs
and on all the tvs are like you know
rainbow flags
and then once everyone's inside you say
everyone gather around for a group photo
and then you press a button all the tvs
turn to trump 2024
and then a bunch of trump flags unfurl
and you've taken pictures
and that's it and then you post them all
on facebook there you go instead of
gender montgomery county
instead of gender reveals you have
political party reveals yeah
all these people show up and they're all
standing there smiling for a photo that
says trump 2024 just like across the
walls banners and then you post it
online they're like i i swear that's not
what i was there for they're gonna feel
like you're lying you're a trump
supporter
it would just cause so much discord
because the left likes eating each other
destroying themselves that it would
eviscerate
there was a guy
there was a guy who's going to all the
protests in 2020 putting trump stickers
on the back of all their cars
didn't someone someone got attacked for
that i think yeah i think there was a
video of like a woman to throw a brick
through her window because someone put
us like a trump sticker on her car at
the protest or something like that
that's crazy that's vandalism by the way
yeah yeah don't put stickers on people's
cars
not your property but in this area you
know even before january 6 the the the
2020 election was so freaking polarized
like there's no way anybody in my
neighborhood even if they were a trump
supporter would have
admitted it in in it with with a yard
sign or something because you are asking
for a brick for your win sure you're
asking for that's why we have secret
ballots because people would get lynched
in the past for that kind of thing so
yep you're gonna know yeah but what you
do is okay it's it's so simple you are
right though i mean activism is so
important you have to make the case you
have to fight for your communities you
have to run for school board you have to
fight back right do you live in like a
residential area with like next door
neighbors are right next to you and
everything so what you got to do is you
got to buy what's called a gilly suit
you know the ghillie suit oh my gosh for
a sniper right yeah it's like it's like
a bushcut you're like you're like yeah
that's what i thought it was i was like
saying this okay
you put the signs up in your yard and
then you get a couple of your friends
maybe your husband and his friends and
they just you know lie out and wait and
then when someone comes by with the
brick they just walk up very very
politely and just grab the brick and say
no well
yes i could also home alone them
the mannequins are like dancing yeah
that you can do well what's that crazy
movie he plays with the tommy gun oh
yeah
two the two robbers joe pescia
daniel stern what an amazing voice over
actor love him he directed uh rookie of
the year the the baseball movie with the
kid you can throw the ball right here
yeah
movie moment with brett yeah
he was he was the voice of the adult
dude on wonder years yeah right wasn't
that him
yes
so we had we had a security issue um i'm
not gonna say exactly where but you know
personal and i was like we had we have
gilly suits because luke
luke bought kelly's suits he looks great
and then i was like all right let's do
this and then
the the issue stopped so it like we
never actually had a chance to get the
guys out in ghillie suits
yeah you got to do a whole show in them
like one whole show just
i do want to point out that like you
mentioned the the part about the
american flags i remember during the
election rogan o'hanley um the dc
draenor he pointed out he said is it
weird that lately just seeing an
american flag i automatically assume
that they're a republican i said uh
because i i'm not a republican and i
know i have friends who are my last boss
at my last job was a you know blue dog
democrat uh believed in owning firearms
but was so anti-trump it was hard to
believe i said i don't think that's
necessarily true that uh somebody's just
because they support the american flag
or that that means that they're
republican but i definitely think that
it does mean a lot to say that they
probably aren't far far left because
they're the ones who every time you have
to post something for fourth of july
there's that one dude who has to come
into your page and be like why would you
post that hate symbol of a flag in your
thing they're just there to ruin
everything well i think that's kind of
what the the issue is is that everything
is such a slippery slope now
into the culture wars and it's like okay
well i want to support you know black
lives matter
and then that turns into now i i can't
you know stand for the anthem and now
the flag is offensive and you have to
support infanticide and you have to
support in fantasy it's a it's a whole
package deal yeah and it's yeah it's
just everything feels like such a
freaking slippery slope now and nobody
wants to touch any issues sheamus made a
good point he said if anything the
left's proven it's not a slippery slope
at all it's a sheer cliff and it's just
straight down
do you think the average person is is
clued into abortion beyond the idea that
they just think it's uh i i hung out in
new york with a friend of mine i've
known for a really long time and he's uh
he talks politics sometimes and he said
this is crazy that they're they're going
to be banning abortion and stuff like
that he wasn't and he wasn't as ignorant
to think that the supreme court decision
did that he was talking about the states
okay and i said
yeah i was like i get it you know
because there there are certain issues
where there have to be exceptions and
stuff like that but look man what's the
alternative the democrats legalize
abortion to the point of birth and he
goes
what no and i was like that's the bill
they just tried to pass and joe
mentioned blocked he goes no that's
that's not true you got to be wrong and
i and i said okay here read it and he
read it and he goes
what and i was like it says
post-viability abortion if the mother's
health is threatened right he goes yeah
yeah that's like a medical issue and i
said what does post-viability mean
and he's like what is it i'm like it
means the baby can survive on its own
and he's like okay and then i'm like
here's the cdc definition of abortion
it ends the life of the baby
and then i'm like this bill legalizes if
the mother is is is in any way at risk
you can terminate the life of a baby
that can survive on its own and he was
like
i don't know this doesn't make sense
this can't be right and i'm like bro i
read this stuff all day every day i just
showed you what more do you have to say
well it's like 100 percent agenda
setting theory i mean this is it's
totally
the mainstream media the media knows
that that is not what
people should hear to support them so
they just don't cover it and then people
don't know
let's say and that's it like for me this
is one of those things where i didn't
get as much pushback on my social media
of people talking about roe v wade as
much as i thought i would but there was
a couple of people who i was actually
surprised talking about in a sense i was
gonna bring up you know third tries like
northam tried to introduce this
ages ago and then you just then you get
into what you're talking about then you
have to have this long conversation with
someone like i don't have the time of
day dude i'm freaking busy during the
day i can't sit here and write and tell
somebody what post-birth abortion is
like you can't abort something that's
been finished that literally makes no
sense but then i have to explain that to
them and i don't have the time of day to
do that always a two-step process you
can't just say what your position is you
have to first explain to them why
they're completely misled and confused
and frankly it's a lot of work and it's
a really good way to lose friends and i
think that's a big part of the problem
is people just don't have the time of
day and doing that communication
digitally doesn't help because
i know you've talked about a lot you
know the concept of conversing with
someone in person is a lot different
than the concept of trying to talk to
someone online where there's no context
where there's no tone of voice yeah well
no even people you agree you like you
generally like or get away or get along
with uh your tone of voice can't be
discerned your body language can't be
discerned and having such a serious
discussion about a topic that important
when you've got 20 minutes free on your
lunch break isn't viable it's not a real
thing thanks for checking out this clip
from timcast irl come hang out live
monday through friday at 8 pm eastern
time super chat we'll even answer some
of your questions if you want to check
out the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you